but the brand that brought you Far Cry 3
Blood Dragon comes three old new
adventures
it's the far cry 5 season pass and
post-launch content in the first steel
sea hours of Darkness you'll be dropped
right in the middle of war-torn Vietnam
as Wendell read ler you'll face Viet
Cong rescue friends and if you've got
the grit get the hell out of there for
an encounter of the radical kind look no
further than the second DLC lost on Mars
your mission is simple save earth by
stopping a full-on alien invasion and
haul ass back home in the third TLC dead
living zombies the deceased ceased to be
decreased as you and a friend melt wave
after wave of zombie hordes in seven
scenarios imagined by B movie director
guy Marvell
and for you VARs fans out there we're
throwing in the full game of Far Cry 3
classic edition how's that for the
definition of insanity and for all Far
Cry 5 players we've got a bunch of
post-launch content as well first up is
Far Cry arcade where there's an endless
amount of maps to play in solo co-op or
PvP created by Far Cry studio as well as
players like you what's more this mode
is constantly updated with new content
and challenges and introducing
reoccurring live events we're going to
give you goals to unlock exclusive
outfits weapons and kick-ass fault
vehicles participate any event sceptile
loot so run those sweet little legs and
get your season pass for the best deal
we've ever offered in Far Cry and stay
tuned for all new content post launch of
Far Cry 5
[Music]
you